вуста не блокпост за три кілометри вигляд
лінії фронту по блузу не старіти вже
витрачайте гроші рішення rnb відсоток 6 про
зуб і на цій землі закупівля ван їм
донбасом у політика жити із пробкою
легально провезти товар і науку когось на
територію та заворотний big поки не було
а ще будуть пробую перетягну
товару який
будемо а ти про знак контрабанди значні
обсяг тодес не будуть за 3-го тис для
подалі та перевірки 1 годину тому та
стильного блокаду відриваючи і нервувати і на
я курс пішов та й ветерани а то почали
скільки мо народного депутата ми маже
два місяці тому активісти розбираються
завищувати свої позиції
оскільки rnb вишитим 6 за барона
торгуватися закуповуємо донбас вам члена
рішення ска суть дієти ми постанова
адже кабміну 5 страх а яке право і
dickie group товарі з дозволяється жадібно
ефективні блокади німа там ще
рішення rainbow суперечити постанові
кабміну вона незаконна c просто люди а
Вакула незаконно прибуває на блокпостах
та роблять вигляд що-небудь обкладають
поразка нас правдиво на вигляд хлопців
захищають сизаль зайво чинах
шляхи
активісти за два місяці зуб похмурим а 60
тисяч вагонів з антрациту
нової для моряків аналіз теплоенергетики
не могла повноцінно протитіти зинку так
та за 1 з 14 лютого майже повністю
запнулася асів я шукати з тут у загартовані
можете просила тобою антрациту який
завезення всіх закупівель їх територій
гривні 100 донбасенерго компетенція
кого накласти теплоелектростанція
купи їх сашка suede оборону на зайнятий
роцит у
закуп про ван йому donbass.ua для
проведення тісного або як таке буває на
підконтрольних києву територіях
мажино і чоловіки в цикл, що в цьому і був
весь до 100 мільйонів євро та двору
будем вид-во paragon вони тут збитки
становлять youtube надлишку становити до
двох з половиною мільйонів гривень на
дугу донбасу нерва доповіді issues і
льоду гармату альтернативної статі вам
троянда ворожать варіанти уста чаю в приділяли
США так і паливо з Америки
з китаю поки що на теплоелектростанції
розбирається незабаром чогось персонал
відправляти людей відпускаючи лося надлишку
компанії вирішили 50 мільйонів гривень ми
працюємо у нас теж нікуди не дінеш
тому що нам спершу треба по-любому
працювати а у птаха був його за свищуть
днів писала рухи на стікаючи по
станції вагоні до теж унушу був з
коротше не
робітників право зберігати говорять що
контролює у символу у ній
автомобільний то залазиш на х і на
плівку до повного донбасу
активісти заявляє, що ти збив ти
мультики своїх пустив ти першона
Вимагаєте виду ряду гарантій України
купівля там його гелю у Росії